[Music]
you done reload
everybody out
Mo you done I'm a
beekeeper I protect the
hive sometimes I use fire to smoke out
Hornets this is a multi-million dollar
operation [__] okay so you can't come
up here here white nigh in
[__] will you stomp his ass out
please I got I got you [__] get him
you [__] get
him
but you feel really proud of
yourself you know I
um I think I should call the
bank you know what you're probably right
but there goes my job and there goes all
your
data
hell my kids pictures are on this
computer
[Music]
okay that is what I am talking about
come
on let
me love you people love
you hello hello you still
there
uh
oh what I'm in a meeting you said hit me
on voice if if there's an emergency okay
right well uh
it seems we had a disgruntled
customer uh I just can't comprehend why
you're bothering me just get in touch
with the attorney and start shoving back
well yeah I I don't think that legal is
going to going to help much okay tell me
what's going on right now this dude just
strolls in saying we're stealing from
people and he just tears through all my
security guys like tissue paper and um
and what any the place to the
ground yeah the call center is gone I'm
standing here staring at a $30 million
building that's it's now giant
astray four people didn't get out you're
telling me that this [__] burnt the
entire building down and dropped four
bodies yeah that's not exactly a
disgruntled customer is it who did this
give me a name right
now okay listen remember our favorite
burning building United a data group
guys who work there are hackers conmen
fraudsters etc etc who ran it Garnett
he's in the book he is a known mob
associate he's missing but I've got PD
chasing him down okay so I had some
analyst friends and I think I'm starting
to get the shape of the animal dude I
think United data group is one of
several call centers so there's got to
be like a central office that's
controlling all of them and that's what
we got to find Wy this could be like a
billion dollar a year
operation hello did you hear a single
word I just said
yeah
and I was just thinking you come in here
hung over on your day off and gain more
yardage on this thing than the whole
squad has in 2 years yeah
well with my
family you're a blessing Mr Clay this
place was crab grass and weeds and you
brought it back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of me
I just got a message saying that there's
a problem with my computer yes ma'am we
got
this here the day she shot herself this
is private property do you know what
they do here scamming the weakest in our
society buddy I'm counted three 1 2
3 there I did it for
you no you can't take it I'm going to
burn this place to the
ground
will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's
not beekeepers is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have laws for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers they cut them off what the
[__] bro don't
move this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam the money's going all to the world
to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming to a street
through the back entrance I figured i'
give the firefighters a break somebody
detain this
guy we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
no
honey it's flammable as [__] who
knew
[Music]
going Jason's playing Adam clay who was
a retired beekeeper he's always like a
super soldier that is there to protect
Society
we meet him living in the barn of a very
sweet lady and she becomes a victim of
cyber crime yesterday she shot herself I
need to take care of the hive it's an
epic Vengeance story about one man's
desire to bring Justice you aware this
is a criminal outfit buddy I'm counted
three 1 2 3 there I did it for you Adam
CLA is on his side of the law which is
the right side will you stomp his ass
out
beekeepers is a special program outside
the chain of
command here is a man who is actually
getting the job
done we have walls for these things
until they fail then you have
me it's Jason Stam so we know the action
is going to be incredible he does his
own stunts and he's absolutely
Relentless once we set things in motion
we're off for a ride this is much bigger
than a little fishing
scam come on R don't
move
going buddy I'm counted three one
three there I did it for you with the
beekeeper it was a lot of fun to
choreograph the fight sequences the
collaboration on the action has been
great the stunt team that we have has
been Second To
None you know David surrounds himself
with great talent you're working
with Jeremy marinus who was my stunt
coordinator it was amazing to watch it
develop and then to shoot these long
takes of of Jason going through all the
qu we didn't double him in that we're
trying to keep things very real and very
efficient that's what Adam clay does he
uses what's available in the
environment he may get a gun take it
apart and turn it into a stabbing
weapon it's a very physical strenuous
activity when we practice and practice
and practice you just grind on the
de it's something that would keep the
action fans on the edge of their seats
these scumbags really get taken
apart
don't
[Music]
move